this is the latest in a series of
outdoor gatherings by palestinians here
in shakeshira in occupied east jerusalem
tensions are always bubbling under here
we saw just how
serious they could become last year in
april and may in a series of pretty
violent confrontations both with
settlers and israeli security forces
really being one of the triggers of the
war that we saw between israel and
fighting factions in gaza they aren't at
that level yet but the constituent
elements are always there the fact that
hundreds of palestinian families face
forced displacement in occupied east
jerusalem and they've been sharpened in
the last few days with what israeli
police say was an arson attack against a
jewish settler home in the neighborhood
there was no one at home but there was
serious damage done to the house there
have been arrests there is a police
investigation underway that is one
factor the other factor is the response
to that by a far-right israeli
politician itamar ben veer
[Music]
benver has set up what he calls an open
air office behind this newly erected
israeli checkpoint in the neighborhood
that office is essentially a desk under
tenting on land belonging to a
palestinian family whose adjacent home
the salem family face forcible
displacement from at some stage during
the month of march now bengali says he's
here to ensure the protection and safety
of jewish settlers in the area but for
palestinian families who live here this
is seen as an extremely provocative act
it's a difficult one for the israeli
establishment to deal with he has
parliamentary immunity so not open to
obvious sanction from israeli security
forces in terms of trying to get him out
of here he's also an enemy really
politically of the right-wing israeli
prime minister naftali bennett so he
doesn't have much leverage over him to
try to persuade him to get out so that
is one factor that is part of the the
growing tensions here once more there is
also the prospect of this family being
evicted during march and in april we see
both ramadan and the jewish passover
falling at the same time so again there
are all the ingredients here of renewed
and potentially dangerous tensions here
in shakespeare
[Music]